- Can you explain to everybody
how you got the role?
- Yeah, I sent Baz a tape.
I heard that he was making the film.
I sent him a tape of me
singing "Unchained Melody",
and playing the piano.
- God, I love that song.
- [Austin] It's such a beautiful song.
- Classic.
- And he responded to it.
And then I flew to New York,
and we met, and we just
talked for three hours,
and then he said you
wanna come in tomorrow,
and read a couple scenes from the script?
And so I came in and read a couple scenes,
and then he said you
wanna come in tomorrow,
and read and sing a couple songs,
and you wanna sing "Suspicious Minds".
And so I went home that night, practiced,
and I come back, we ended up
doing that for five months.
It was unlike any audition,
where it was five months of exploring.
- That's a relationship.
- Yeah
- Yeah.
- Completely, and then it
came time for the screen test,
which...
- Then it came time for the?
Okay.
- Because you know there comes a point
where the studio has to sign off.
And there, you gotta do the screen test.
And so I'd prepared everything,
and got to the screen test,
and Baz changed everything
on me on the day.
I was supposed to do a couple scenes,
and he changed the scenes,
and changed all the words in the scenes.
And then I was supposed
to sing three songs.
He said, and then he starts
describing the scene to me.
And he's saying, you're
gonna sing these three songs,
and they weren't the
songs that I prepared.
And so suddenly I'm on set.
and I go Baz I don't
think I have the material
that you gave me.
And he goes, oh no, we changed it,
but I'll get you new material.
And then turns out he never
got me a new material,
and he starts filming while
I'm learning everything.
So then I started going through it,
and then he cut one of the scenes,
and he said now we're
gonna do you performing
"Suspicious Minds".
- Is he just like messing
with you at this point?
- I realize now...
- I would look around for
Ashton Kutcher at this point.
Like, am I being punked?
- Being punked, yeah.
- That's horrible.
- He put me through the ringer,
and I realize now it's 'cause that's,
he likes to be very spontaneous on set.
He wanted to see if I would lose my mind.
And so I didn't think I got it.
And then a week later I got a call,
and I woke up to Baz calling me,
and I thought, okay
this is a moment I either
have it or I don't.
And he's very dramatic in the
way that he goes about things.
And so he sounded kind of downcast
and he goes
- Oh, how mean!
- I just wanted to be the
first one to call you and say,
are you ready to fly Mr. Presley?
- Oh my gosh.
- It was just the greatest
phone call I've ever had.
- I love that.